now we're ready for Newton's third law
and Newton's third law in some ways I
think is the most fun because it's it's
it's at least it was to me the least
intuitive of are all the laws but once
you really kind of understand it a lot
of things start to make sense so
Newton's third law essentially says
actually I can I can tell you kind of
what you might have heard you know a lot
of people say every action has an equal
and opposite reaction another way of
thinking about it is if there's an
object and it exhort exerts a force on
another object so let's say I have a oh
let me think of something let's say I
let's say that I have a fist so let me
draw the fist so I have a fist and it is
punching someone's face so this is the
face and they're not happy right and
let's say this fist is punching the face
with the force of I don't know ten
Newtons
let's not make it so vile let's say that
this is a hand massaging the face it's
pressing upon the face with a force of
10 Newtons
so what Newton's third law tells us is
that the face is also I guess we could
say punching the hand or well no we're
not using the violent the face is also
pressing upon the hand with a force of
10 Newtons in the opposite direction but
along the same I guess you could say it
along the same line so what does that
make any sense because it seems like the
hand is doing something to the face and
not the other way around but if you
think about it when you press on
someone's face their face might kind of
press in a little bit but you also feel
something on your on your on your fist
or on your hand I mean think of it maybe
a better example would be instead of
someone's face imagine if it was a a
tree that you've decided to massage or I
guess punch so here is the tree that is
the tree and the same thing would happen
you if you were to press upon the tree
with if you were to punch the tree
essentially
the tree is essentially punching back
with the exact same force and here it
makes sense because your hand will hurt
and maybe in this case the face will
hurt because the face kind of gives way
while your fist doesn't but here the
tree is not giving away in your fist
will another way to think about it is if
well then this is probably the least
intuitive if I have the earth if I have
the earth and here my standing on top of
the earth so we already figured out that
the pull of the earth or the force of
gravity upon me it's pulling down upon
me at 150 pounds that's the force and
you know we could say to Newton but
pounds is a unit of force its weight but
it also Newton's third law tells us that
I'm actually at the same moment pulling
on the earth with a force of 150 pounds
and this not met me not this might not
make a lot of sense to you but you could
think about it this way when I'm
stepping on let's say I'm stepping on a
soft surface like sand or something I
feel my my feet will compress a little
bit but so does the sand probably by you
know well depending on on which one
softer and and so and another way to
think about it also is if I'm if me and
the earth are both in deep space right
and I am you could say falling towards
the earth because the earth is pulling
on me how do we know that the earth
isn't falling towards me I mean it's
it's kind of arbitrary there's no frame
of reference we're both in deep space
there's nothing else to look at we're
essentially falling towards each other
I'm not necessarily falling to the earth
the Earth's not necessary fine to me
we're just falling towards each other
and that's another way of thinking about
this so you can think about every
example where a force applies to
something and if you really think about
it the force is going the other way as
well for example if I were to take a bat
to this tree so if I were to take a bat
to this tree and swing on it really hard
so I would have swing on this tree
really hard I have a good chance of
breaking that bat even though you would
have thought hey that bat is applying
the force to the tree well why is the
bat breaking because the tree is
applying an equal force to the bat and
actually if I did it perfectly if I had
like let's say I had two bats up or two
swords and I for some reason I think I'm
I'm I'm going a little too violent with
the examples but I guess you know we're
talking about forces so so maybe
violence is justified here but let's say
I have two swords that are completely
identical hitting each other right and
at some point and let's say I keep
increasing the force at which they're
kind of going in opposite directions at
some point they're going to break right
if I just keep increasing the force on
you know one guy swinging in one
direction one guy swinging in the exact
opposite direction and and the force
just keeps increasing keeps me at both
at some point they're going to break and
you could say that well you know this
guy says well I was the only guys
swinging because this guy was stationary
and the other guy was saying well I was
the only guy swinging because this guy
was stationary but somebody not one of
them's going to break they're both going
to break because even though this move
sword was was pushing on this this this
blue sword with some force the blue
sword was essentially pushing back with
the exact same force so these are
completely identical swords at some
point they're going to break another way
we could think about one of the swords
could have just been held
you know stationary it could have been
held stationary by somebody and this
other sword that if you were to press
down and kept increasing the force with
which you press at some point they both
would break because when they're
identical if if one was harder than the
other then that would stick around
hopefully that gives you a little
intuition I mean we could we could do a
bunch of more examples I'm trying to
think oh well let me think of another
one let's find one let's say we're in
deep space again and I have a I don't
know I have a basketball we're doing
orange I have a basketball and it weighs
one kilogram and let's say that I weigh
let's say that I weigh 50 kilograms
so let's say I push so my hand pushes on
this ball with a force of I don't know
let's say I push on that ball with a
force of 10 Newtons 10 Newtons to the
right what this tells me with Newton's
third law tells me is that essentially
that basketball is going to push on my
hand with an equal and opposite force so
it's going to push on me with the force
of 10 Newtons so what's going to happen
so we're touching I'm pushing on 10
Newtons on the basketball we're in deep
space there's no gravity from random
Stars etc etc and then the basketballs
going to push on me with the force of 10
Newtons simultaneously so the basketball
we know that F equals MA so the
basketball so 10 Newton's is equal to
one kilogram times acceleration so
acceleration is going to be 10 meters
per second squared to the right so as
long as we're touching the basketball is
going to accelerate at 10 meters per
second squared to the right and
simultaneously I'm going to accelerate
at a certain acceleration to the left
and what's that going to be whoops I'm
50 kilograms so we know that the force
to the left is also going to be tens and
that equals 50 kilograms times
acceleration
so here the acceleration is going to be
1/5 meters per second squared so when I
push on so we're both in deep space
floating around and I push on this one
kilogram basketball with a force of 10
Newtons it's going as long as I'm
pushing on it it's going to accelerate
at 10 meters per second squared
as long as I'm pushing on it but
simultaneously while I'm pushing on it
it's exit it's exerting an equal and
opposite force of me on 10 Newton's so
I'm going to actually move back a little
bit at us at a slower acceleration
that's just because I have more mass at
1/5 meters per second squared another
example you could think of is if someone
shoots a gun right there's that I forgot
the term because I don't shoot guns but
you know when that that your shoulder
jerks back is I've seen in the movies
when a bullet is shot and that's because
the gun is exerting a force on that
bullet and the bullet is exerting an
equal and opposite force on the gun or
on and which
kind of pushes back on your shoulder and
the reason why the bullet just goes a
lot lot faster forward then you and the
gun go backwards is because your mass is
much much much larger than the bullet
hopefully that gives you a little bit of
intuition on Newton's third law and is
this is kind of not intuitive so you
look around you in the world look at all
the forces that are being applied and I
want you to think about you know when
one force is being applied in one
direction why does it make sense that
another force an equal and opposite
force is being applied in the exact
opposite direction I'll see you all in
the next video